I think one of the more interesting
things is focused now on individual
differences you know with you condition
10 rats or 20 rats to be afraid of a
sound paired with a shock and you find
that some are very afraid and some are
not very for hidden the others are come
in the middle and so the typical way of
dealing with that is you average it all
together and you get the mean and that's
what you study the outliers are viewed
as kind of a nuisance that adds variance
to the data but now we've begun to study
those previous nuisances and try to
understand a little more about you know
what's really going on in terms of
pathological fear because almost all the
the drugs that are developed to treat
fear and anxiety are developed on that
average animal rather than the extremes
but what we really need to understand I
think in the drug should be much more
effective and perhaps have fewer side
effects if they were targeted for the
animals with the extreme fear so we're
trying to come at the question of what
causes animals to have this extreme fear
what pushes them out to the ends of the
distribution the the basic idea is that
yeah one way to do this would be to take
animals that that have the extremes
period and then start breeding them and
create genetic lines that are that are
fearful but I think it's also
interesting to ask given that it already
exists in the population of rats there's
extreme behaviors what can we learn
about so the pathophysiology of extreme
fear by studying those animals in other
words we don't have to start breeding
and creating genetic lines to get at
what's different because the difference
is already there we can compare animals
that are really afraid and those that
are not afraid and look in their brains
and see if they're Annie for example
structural differences in the amygdala
in terms of how the neurons what their
dendritic branches are what their axons
are like what kinds of molecules are
present in those neurons and to what
extent so we can get a lot of
information that might distinguish
fearful and
not so fearful rats that could provide
important clues as to what pushes them
out there towards the extremes but that
projects just beginning so we don't have
any answers but I think it's it's going
to be an important project